partout pour le bio france 3 bourgogne
du creusot andré billardon nous aurons
nous attend et nous entend aussi bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous quatrième mandat
pour vous mais au deuxième tour cette
fois andré billardon c'était plus dur
cette campagne par rapport aux
précédentes
a beaucoup plus dur en effet
les résultats du second tour pas tout à
fait serré puisque l'écart entre mon
adversaire et moi-même et et de quatre
points il n'en reste pas moins que la
situation a nécessité naturellement une
campagne extrêmement active entre les
deux tours dès lors d'ailleurs que que
mon adversaire
proférées à la fois mensonge
approximations parfois insultes et quand
j'entends évoqué les différences entre
la droite républicaine et l'extrême
droite je note que dans un certain
nombre d'endroits les méthodes de la
droite ne sont pas très éloignées de
celles de l'extrême droite est à cela le
creusot n'était pas habitué nous avons
dû faire face est celui qui ambitionnait
d'être le maire du creusot au bout du
compte a échoué mais ça nécessitait de
notre part une campagne extrêmement
active et très militante dans les
derniers jours andré billardon question
d' eric sicaud oui et donc vous avez été
mis en ballottage quand même pour la
première fois vous pour vous est-ce que
c'est quand même dû à quelques
phénomènes locaux ou est ce que c'est
vraiment la vague bleue et tout cet
effet là qui vous a mis en difficulté
mais c'est d'abord pour une raison
simple lorsque il ya deux listes il n'y
a pas de deuxième tour et dans
l'histoire du creusot il n'y avait
jamais eu de liste aux élections
municipales donc il n'y avait jamais eu
par nécessité par droit de
tour cette fois ci quatre listes au
premier tour le ballottage m'a été
imposée par la dispersion des voix et
pas par le fait de la droite plutôt par
la dispersion extrême gauche et
écologistes et au deuxième tour je me
suis employé à assembler pas autant que
je leur ai souhaité pas autant qu'on
l'aurait souhaité et au bout du compte
néanmoins avec une étiquette socialiste
qui n'est pas la plus porteuse il faut
bien dire les choses comme elles sont
dans la période actuelle nous l'avons
emporté